don't over inspect don't over supervise
hard to do that your ego wants you to
over supervise by the way your ego wants
to over inspect your ego actually wants
to find problems you ever had those
bosses then you can't get through like
in the SEAL Teams you give a brief
there's no way you're getting through
the brief without getting dinged on
seven different things I'd like some of
the guys I used to critique their briefs
on come and talk to me because I was
freaking harsh on those briefs but
here's the thing man I'll have to review
some of my notes because I would be
harsh because they would do dumb [__]
and I'd be like bro what are you doing
over here what does this mean I can't
even understand look at your pictures
here like this doesn't make any sense
what is this timeline how do you think
you're gonna Patrol from here to here in
that amount of time they were just
legitimate things because I actually
didn't care I actually didn't care what
the font was I didn't care about any of
that